let's talk about one thing is truth
social yeah so uh i have truth social
here and uh this is what my truth social
dashboard looks like so when uh cash got
here you mentioned truth you are like
truthing something i think the branding
is bad by the way like truthing it i
don't know but you know i just got to be
honest all right well i was thinking
confirm could be a good one i will
confirm it and then how many
confirmations did you get that'd be a
cool thing you should have just shouted
that out when trump was on the phone
when we before the show
get better branding
i i heard a great meme they were like
trump should have called it kaffifi
everyone would have wanted the kaffi app
like i gotta get it it would have been
trump's but uh so so you mentioned you
know getting truth social and i gotta i
gotta be honest engagement is nuts
that's great people on truth social
cause i was ragging on it a while ago
because it was like locked up and nobody
was using it trump wasn't even on now
it's flowing i went i went and looked at
it
and all of a sudden i have like all of
these i posted something nonsensical and
i get all these crazy you know comments
and i start looking at other users and
seeing this massive engagement that i
didn't see before so before the show you
mentioned i'm like i don't have an
iphone and you were like just pull up on
the browser and i was like you can do
that now pulled up on the browser
and there it is now i can use it in my
browser or whatever so
truth social actually has substantial
engagement i mean you were mentioning
you got how many followers six hundred
thousand and i'm not even 100 000
followers
and uh it was at the same time elon musk
was announcing he's gonna buy twitter
truth social spikes in the app store so
i'll tell you this this seems to be
it's almost like i don't know a
snowball rolling down a hill
something that's actually competing with
these big tech silicon valley uh
platforms what i find interesting is the
timing of elon musk wanting to come in
and buy twitter
at a time when truth social is coming
out and basically getting all of these
trump supporting populist types to join
the platform if there's one thing that
could potentially stop that it's elon
musk coming in pulling twitter back i
wonder how much of this was elon
recognizing
he said it that people are leaving too
truth social because of the censorship i
wonder if he was like i can make money
if i stop that and bring these people
back you know maybe i mean i don't know
i don't know what's going to happen on
that
that twitter deal but you know i have to
say as a disclosure i'm a member of the
board of directors for tmtg that owns
street social so no they don't pay me i
just get to do more work for free but
but basically what actually i want while
you have your picture up tim so tim and
i don't think everybody knows this we
are having a a times square billboard
off
i literally have a plot against the king
billboard along with a kovid jab
billboard right next to tim's billford
but it's mine's only 30 feet not 70 feet
so you won this round
but uh we why did we did it for the same
reason we want to go into the lion's den
and be like why can't we blast out we
last week we did a whole billboard on
russiagate in durhamwatch.com this week
we're selling the book the plot against
the king why not and it's like you said
i don't know that's going to get much
you know generate a lot of business but
the point is we're there oh here's what
i want to point out too when you look at
this image i want you all to understand
here's the billboard okay and you may be
wondering tim okay you got yourself a
billboard that's cool but like what's
what's culture jamming about it's like
what's
it just got a billboard right so i
talked about how we never spent any
money on marketing for this show until
now
and we want to do culture jamming his
marketing ladies and gentlemen this is
above the abc news building
you can see right here abc news espn
with all their fancy marquee and
everything and i am on top
so these many of these blue check
journalists most of them probably don't
care some are probably fans they're
probably cool yeah but some of these
snooty people these corporate press
these shills on these morning shows they
get to walk in in the morning and look
up and who's on top of their building so
it is a simple message to the elites
that you are not the elites anymore
these people who think they're the best
the the smartest they're the strongest
no no no we are we are coming we are
asserting ourselves in the space i was
excited for this one i didn't know it
was going to go up so early it was
supposed to go up in four days but they
put it up early so it's good and that's
why we also like gave a nod to truth
social on on one of these billboards
that we're doing last week or the next
week and and i got to bring up how we
brought uh the beginning of the show
again so yes i did agree and i did ask
president trump to go on tim poole tim
cast and he did say yes he said it was
the greatest show everyone agrees you
know at least that's what he was told i
believe that's what i said and uh but
there was you know hey there was a
bargain in place i i'm challenging the
tim castors to go out and buy as many
copies of the plot against the king as
they can because if they push through
then i'm going to work my tail off to
make sure that tim cast with trump
actually happened that was the quid pro
quo yeah that's an actual quick profile
i'll advertise it as that hell yeah man
where can people buy it the plot against
the king dot com
yeah nice very easy it's idiot russia
gate for kids it's russiagate for kids
how could you not want to read this
story adults should read this story it's
super fun there's pictures i can read it
it's at my level i got through the first
page already i liked it when you were
talking to trump i could sort of hear
some of it and i'm like it has to be
fake because it was so perfectly trump
oh man it's like
it sounds like a recording of him you
know like cash comes in here and he
presses play on a video like talking i'm
not gonna i'm talking to trump i swear
now i can get him on your show you sell
books for me and then it's like it's a
video that's a quick pro quo i got to
make up for 16 years of being poor in
government and educating children i
remember regarding truth it had a rocky
start because they used mastodon code
but it's what they had to it was a free
software license code i don't know what
they use exactly what the licensing code
was uh but it was they were supposed to
show the the software code because they
were reusing it as per the and they
didn't and uh that really bothered me
and set me off but the upside is it's
using mastodon code which means we can
federate the thing and create
interoperability between networks so
like if you're logged into minds or
truth social or twitter if we can get
ahold of twitter's software licensing
codes
we'll be able to you'll be able to
message someone on truth social from
your twitter account and vice versa and
create like a network of networks i
think truth will be a great part of that
this time to graphene
i'm into that i have some right here
would you like to tie it into graphing i
think every everybody's graphing wiring
everybody's been ragging on ian because
they're saying boraphine is the future
and he's living 20 years in the past
it's the fiend it's the structure that's
important not necessarily the carbon
itself although carbon's pretty cool
because if you have this uh hexagonal
lattice uh structure nanostructure of
like a monoatomic layer of chemicals
apparently boron's equally as cool as
what are you use that for
some dude touch screen wallpaper you can
you can make clothing that's touch
screen super capacitor battery your
clothing can be batteries you're like i
can get donald we i think donald can run
on this stuff because this is going to
be the industry of the 21st century it's
going to be the new steel people are
going to be making buildings out of it
uh wiring out of it touch screen all of
this and if he can bring enough
scientists around to create the greatest
graphene like if we can make the
greatest graphene production facility on
earth in the united states i have an
idea why don't we get
when when donald trump devin and myself
do a tim cast live from uh one of his
properties we have it sponsored by
graphene and we put it on truth social
and then everybody wins yeah there you
go we'll find a company that makes it i
really need to start something in the
united states that builds it you know
check this out i bought stock i bought
stock in a company that makes graphene
because ian wouldn't shut up about it
and it's like one of my only stocks
that's still up despite like the market
at 2029 we're going to see peak
implementation of this stuff you're
going to start but the problem is the
copper industry it doesn't want to lose
their wiring
um so that's going to be a challenge to
disrupt the copper industry but we'll be
able to repurpose the copper i think you
can deposit carbon dioxide i believe
onto copper and create graphene out of
it you can actually get carbon dioxide
out of the air and turn it into graphene
you don't be funny he's like dialed in
he is you know it'll be really funny
it's like we do a show with trump and
then ian starts going off on graphene
and then trump just gets zoned in and
he's like tell me more and then just
like all of a sudden trump's doing
pressers he's speaking and he's running
for office and he's just all about
gravity the future the new manufacturing
the new steel we're going to bring all
these jobs ian is sitting there you know
just he retires because he knows he's
done everything he can everything he
needs to do nothing we'll be able to
pull carbon dioxide out of the
atmosphere to kind of balance out the
carbon emission type thing but we're
going to have to be careful that we
don't pull too much out too fast and set
up an industry that sucks it all out
because we'll begin competing with trees
we are going to name you the ambassador
for graphene let's do it baby
we can help a lot of people we're a
graphene czar if you can build a space
elevator it's better than the
disinformation czar
2024.
the the votes come in
ian gets on the phone and says i want
that position as graphics are i was
promised
[Laughter]
i just want to go to space graphing
ballots
well so the original idea was like what
i wanted to bring up with truth social
was that it's it's allowing people to
maintain their conversations
twitter was trying to silence people
youtube's trying to silence people
they're trying to control the narrative
to a degree
where
i was talking to this guy we might have
i think we're playing on heaven the show
his name is mike benz yeah and uh he was
explaining how the goal of
like
national security uh officers and things
like this and big tech
is to
censor just enough
so you can make your opponents
politically ineffective but not silenced
because they know that if you censor
people you get bat you get a backlash so
they want just a little bit
just enough to where they get a head
start in the race
truth social is basically cutting that
off
people are able to go back on and follow
trump once again and and people are
posting and sharing what he says and i'm
seeing journalists when trump re-truth
the words civil war mainstream press was
forced to talk about it
and that puts truth social front and
center the more he does that the more
they're forced to talk about it and
that's why he's never going back to
twitter i mean that in the fact that he
owns the company but people keep asking
me that and i'm like no he's not going
back on any other platform he doesn't
want back on youtube or twitter or i
don't even know what the other ones are
called but his this is going to be it
it's either you know and i think it's
going to succeed and if you look at the
bots we were talking about dean and i
before right ian what elon has done is
basically proven the concept that devin
and i proved on the side of russiagate
is twitter
suppressing free speech and are there
bots the answer to both those questions
was affirmative for sure elon has
finally put those facts out for the
mainstream media and forced them to take
them on up to 50 bots that's a lot and
also the freedom of speech depression we
can't get that kind of campaign out but
he's proven that and now they have to
address it now they hate him for it and
now the fact that he said he's voting
republican i think they've they're going
to come after him pretty hard but if you
can build a company on truth social that
has 15 million 20 million people you
know by the end of the year or something
like that that's a company that's legit
half as big as twitter how many users do
you know how many users aren't true i
know that i think president trump has
like
four million yeah yeah or something like
that so just do some math maybe there's
four to seven on there right now i bet
everybody's following trump yeah so he's
got three point one million followers
okay and then android engagement is
massive no it's it's it's mine take a
look at the new york times on twitter
nobody nobody retweets
so i can i can certainly say like i
never uh like tweet at the new york
times there's no conversation there so
when people are like no one's responding
to them like yeah who cares but nobody's
even retweeting their stories because i
do retweet stories when i see a big
story i'll be like oh you know you know
i basically retweet so i can come back
later and look through the stories that
i was seeing but people don't even do
that for the new year i just put out i
just put out a truth on the car ride
over here for for my handle at cash for
your i was saying i was coming on tim on
tim cass thousands of people in the car
ride on the way over
were responding to that like physically
writing and responding and re-truthing
and reposting that i was doing the show
and and there was and there was
conversations on both sides oh i hate
you cash i loved him i hate him actually
cash sucks and so that's what you want
that's the whole point and it's human
beings engaging on truth and it's fun
and the fun the funnest part is these
things called pinata farms i don't know
if you guys have seen these but they
take real life movies and they stick
your heads on them so there's one of
like me and trump perp walking hillary
clinton out of the detention center and
it's just built into the platform well
there's a yeah this company has just
built it into this thing and it's now
it's all over the place and it's for
anything and everything it's hilarious
that's like the beginning of deep fakes
they're gonna people are gonna but you
can't you can tell it's like a joke it's
like an oversized head on like a smaller
box
truth social issue like jib jab yeah
yeah or the reface app yeah call fifi is
trending of course you know i just think
truth is the perfect like it's so
trumpian calling it truth yeah truth is
subjective like what one person believes
is true another person might see
differently and think that it's not true
but we're both looking at the same thing
well it's kind of an evolution to we
have the fake news and now we have truth
it's like dark to light it's the inn and
the yang i love that how they tried
using fake news against trump and then
trump turned it around against them and
it was brilliant you are fake news yeah
it was part of it as part of the counter
intel operation we ran for the last five
years i wanted joe biden to go and spend
a half a million dollars coming up with
ultra mega
then i was gonna then i was gonna have
president trump release my book on truth
social the plot against the king the
very next day and we've had the most
successful book launch um i can't
believe they did the ultra maga thing
it's just they they they said that the
data shows
middle middle america like like suburban
you know people don't like maga and so
that's why they're going for it but what
they never understood it just shows they
never understood the maga people the
trump supporters the right
trump got memed into office
people were posting jokes they were
having a laugh they're having a good
time the picture you ever see that
picture where trump is on a tank it's
like a golden tank or something he's
like standing like an eagle thing it's
all funny it's just like supposed to be
crazy or trump's face as rocky balboa
like ripped body and everything and they
think it's real
they're like these trump people are in a
cult no they're joking i was picturing
them coming out and say shot on it and
being like ultra mugger and then like
the fireworks shootout behind them but
people would love it but then i think
the media like rachel maddow would get
afraid because they'd be like oh it's
ultra mega is real like i don't know
because i want to have fun with it it's
hilarious
hey you know why i don't read the new
york times why i don't repost new york
times because you got to pay money to
read their articles whenever i go to a
new york times article i can't get past
the first paragraph so i just give up on
it and move on i don't read it because
i'm suing them for defamation oh good
but there you go what did they say uh
they them politico and cnn called me
trump's ukraine whisperer
and
injected me into an impeachment fiasco
and i said okay what's that based on
like was there a meeting do you have a
witness and if you remember that clown
fiona hill came in and said oh cash
patel ukraine whisper and then under
oath in front of the world during the
impeachment trial fiona hill goes well
i've never met cash we've never spoken
and i don't really know him well then
how am i
the the guy so i'm suing them all that's
what fight with cash is all about like
that's my attempt to fix the media is
we're raising money we're actually suing
on behalf of other american citizens
who've been to fame we've cut the check
for their lawyer thanks for checking out
this segment from the tim cast irl
podcast but if you want to check out the
full show live tune in monday through
friday at 8 pm and if you want more
special access content head over to
timcast.com and become a member your
membership helps sustain this company
keep our journalists employed makes this
show happen and you will get access to
exclusive members only segments of the
tim cast irl podcast and there is a
massive library to check out so again go
to timcast.com or tune in monday through
friday at 8pm and we'll see you all
there
you